do you think time is fundamental or or
emergent
I think ultimately it has to be emergent
yeah what does it mean for time to be
emergent well
because let's review what it means for
space to be emergent
yes what it means for space to be
emergent is that
um you you have a holographic plate
and you shine some light that's moving
in space
and it produces an image
which contains an extra spatial
dimension
and time just goes along for the ride
so what we'd like to
do and indeed there is some rather
concrete
work in this direction though again I
would say even within our stringing
Community we're not getting a pluses on
these efforts
but what we'd like to do is to see
um
examples in which the extra space-time
dimension
is time in other words
usually what what we understand very
well mathematically is how to take
systems
uh
in
some number of space-time dimensions
and rewrite them as a plate in fewer
space dimensions
what we'd like to do is to take systems
with
one time and some number of space
dimensions and to rewrite them is a
system that had only space dimensions in
it had no time evolution
and there's some fairly concrete ideas
about how to do that but they're not
you know universally accepted even
within the
stringy community
but isn't it well to you
yes for to be emergent how do we Intuit
these kinds of ideas as human beings for
whom space and time seems as
fundamentals as apples and oranges both
Illusions okay they're both illusions
even time